now as you may know i've done a lot of videos
on the gallbladder and bile salts because of the
great importance of that organ which is typically
considered an extra organ that you don't need but
the gallbladder is very very important it
helps you store and concentrate bile salts
now your liver makes bile and so do your friendly
bacteria now about 95 to 97 of all the bile that
you your body makes is recycled so bile is very
very important and when you take bile salts as a
supplement normally people take that with a
meal they might take it just after they eat
and it will usually help with bloating belching
burping and nausea now the primary function of
bile salts that most people know is the
extraction of the fat soluble vitamins
from the fat in your diet but there are many
other benefits of using purified bowel salts
and taking them on an empty stomach now i've
pretty much purchased every single medical
textbook on both the gall bladder and bile salt
so it's a fascinating topic i want to share with
you the nine benefits of taking purified bile
salts and for these benefits i'm going to discuss
i would recommend taking purify bath salts on an
empty stomach i would take one in the morning and
one in the afternoon all right number one taking
purified bile salts can help you reduce the risk
of getting gallstones why because a gallstone is
a super concentrated gallbladder crystal compound
and bile salts help you prevent the formation
of cholesterol crystals okay that's number one
number two it helps you extract the fat soluble
vitamins vitamin a e d vitamin k and the omega-3
fatty acids and what it does to fat is it
emulsifies the fat it breaks down the fat
into these small particles which increase the
surface area so the pancreas can release its
enzyme called lipase which then does the rest
of the dissolving of that fat particle so you
can fully extract those nutrients from that food
and so you need both bile and the enzyme from
the pancreas to make this successful all right
number three it can help you with constipation
bile is kind of a lubricant it helps to lubricate
the colon and so when you're deficient in bile you
can become constipated now if you have too
much bile you can get diarrhea because it
actually releases a lot of water in through the
intestines specifically the large intestine so
that's why you need just the right amount number
four bile helps you convert thyroid hormones t4
is the inactive version of the thyroid hormone and
t3 is the active form you need bile to make this
transition from t4 to t3 and this is why sometimes
when people have their gallbladder removed
and they become gallbladder deficient they may
end up with a thyroid problem the simple solution
is just to start taking purified bowel salts
because that will help the thyroid greatly and
one contraindication of taking purify bile salts
is if you have too many thyroid hormones so if you
have a hyperthyroid condition you never want to
take bile salts because that's going to increase
more conversion and make things worse but
for a hypo thyroid condition purified bile
salts can help you greatly now number five is
very interesting bile salts can act as a vdr
agonist now what the heck does that mean
vitamin d receptor agonist bile helps you
trigger the receptor for vitamin d now this is
very important in autoimmune diseases because
the problem with autoimmune conditions is that
you have this massive inflammation and vitamin
d is the most important vitamin in dropping
inflammation and if you have an autoimmune
condition and you don't have any inflammation you
really don't have hardly any symptoms from that
condition and so bile can help you indirectly
reduce inflammation in the body especially the
liver all right number six bile salts can help
you decrease pain in your body specifically in
the right shoulder simply because if you have
a congested gallbladder or there's congestion
between the liver and the ducts going to the gall
bladder or the small intestine a lot of times
this bile will form sludge because you're missing
bile and that congestion will back up the pipes
and put pressure into the liver and cause pain in
the right shoulder as well as trigger a nerve that
goes from your diaphragm up to your neck called
the phrenic nerve and cause right shoulder pain
right trap pain up through here pain in the
rhomboid muscle in the back part here it can also
cause pain on the right side causing a headache on
the right side of your head it can also cause pain
and tightness underneath the right rib cage or in
the stomach area or underneath the left ribcage
and even pancreatitis because what can happen
is this bile sludge can back up and now you have
your bile salts which are detergents that
are not moving properly and they're stuck
in the bile ducts in the liver and even in the
pancreatic ducts and if it's stagnant or doesn't
move that can create inflammation and so by
taking purified bile salts that thins the sludge
and allows things to drain through and the
pain goes away and so a lot of the pain
problems are coming from a deficiency of bile and
as a side note let me just mention the reasons
why you might be deficient in bile number one you
have the gallbladder removed number two you're on
a low fat diet number three you're taking too
many omega-6 fatty acids as in soy oil canola
cottonseed oil corn oil all these cooking
vegetable oils that we consume are very very
damaging to the liver and they can create a big
problem if you're consuming too much sugar refined
grains or you have a spike in insulin that can
decrease your bile if you're estrogen dominant
or you're taking birth control pills and the
estrogen spikes that can create a deficiency in
bile if your liver is fatty or you have hepatitis
or you have cirrhosis and there's liver damage
that can decrease the production of bile right
there if you have high levels of cortisol or
you're taking prednisone which is a type of
cortisol that can create a deficiency of bile
soy protein isolates can greatly aggravate the
gallbladder and the liver and cause a deficiency
of bile having too many exotoxins let's say for
example you did a detox and you're breaking up
bacteria or virus particles and that's releasing
these endotoxins which by the way create the detox
reactions that occur when you do a detox what
happens to a lot of people is they get this stuck
flow in the liver and the bile is not going to
drain properly and so one of the things that i
always recommend when you do a detox especially a
liver detox is to first take purified bile salts
get the drainage occurring first so you don't
get this backup of toxins in the liver which
is very very uncomfortable another cause
is malabsorption if you have gut damage
you're not going to be able to recycle bile since
95 97 of all the bile in your body is recycled
if the end part of your small intestine is damaged
or you have inflammation and you can't recycle
that you're going to be deficient in bile and the
last reason why you might be deficient in bile
is you don't have enough good bacteria all right
let's get back to the benefits number seven purify
bio salts help reduce the risk of small intestinal
bacterial overgrowth sibo why because bile is
toxic to bacteria and one of the things that bile
does as it's released into the small intestine
is it kills off all the bacteria in your small
intestine and that way you prevent bacteria from
growing in the wrong place and so bile travels
all the way down through the small intestine
kills off the bacteria make sure it doesn't grow
and then right at the last part it gets reabsorbed
so most of the bile is reabsorbed into the liver
and so very little bile enters the small intestine
and this way we keep the bacteria in the right
place the large intestine and if there's a problem
with this and some of that bile gets into the
large intestine that's when you have diarrhea
all right number eight and i already mentioned
this but bile greatly helps reduce inflammation
in your liver it's a paddle protective it
protects the liver all right last one is this
purified bile salts reduce the toxic load so
the toxins that are filtered out to the liver
need bile salts to help push them out through
the small intestine and out through the large
intestine and they also help regulate excessive
amounts of cholesterol all right there you have
it the nine benefits of taking purified bowel
salts before you go if you have a question about
a product or you're new to keto and you want to
know how to begin keto or you're on keto and you
need a debug because it's not going as smooth i
have a keto consultant standing by to help you
this is just for the people in the US hopefully in
the future we'll be able to answer everyone's call
but i put the number down below
so you can call and get some help